[Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  hi i'm lee smith the founder of lost  years the run brand dedicated to saving  endangered sea turtles  first and most important for us is the  money that we raise together with our  customers  that goes directly to funding sea turtle  conservation  in the caribbean latin america  so every bottle sold saves 10 baby sea  turtles  it's a very much a small family business  i think for for us as a family um we're  not major eco warriors or anything like  that but we've grown increasingly aware  of the challenges that our planet is  facing we can also  create a product that is pretty  sustainable that uses recycled  recyclable materials uses zero plastic  and those are the sorts of things we're  trying to do and trying to champion  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  the sea turtle has been on our planet  for 110 million years and we'd like to  see them continue for that amount of  time too  i certainly don't want them to disappear  on our watch